foreign
[Music]
we get people from all around so
sometimes things do Get Lost in
Translation you want me to quilt I made
a whip a quilt a quilt yeah one word and
three people heard three different
things even before I became a
veterinarian I was a veterinary
technician there was a dog that had a
fractured leg so the doctor said he had
to put a pen in and some y on it so she
kept looking and she was saying you're
gonna put some a y like the letter Y on
it he was like oh no wire w-i-r-e my mom
pillow what's a pillow a pillow pillow a
pillow oh you're from Georgia too you
got a pillow too sometime we say things
you just don't understand what we're
saying if you're Southern you get it go
spend the day down here with us
don't you'll lead it in a day saying I
don't know what I'm talking about but my
dog's been on my dog yeah
[Music]
hey how y'all hello how you doing all
right how you doing dear I'm fine how
are you all right all right tell me a
little bit about this baby four-year-old
shitzu nebby was born hermaphrodite
wow okay
we're running into a few issues and some
Oddities and all that are normal dog and
I wouldn't have he thinks like a little
boy thinks like a little boy yeah all
right so you sometimes hump and show
some meal characters a strong male dog
yeah we're running into a few issues
with some bleeding and stuff gosh okay
wow that is different
testicles are here and then straight
down as his little female so when he
goes to the bathroom I have to bathe him
every time he don't go out in the yard
because this is open wow no I was here
today because he has a penis that is
continuously getting irritated and
infections and inflammation around the
previous so what I'm gonna attack it is
I'm going definitely neuter I'm gonna
try to close that penis in there I'm
gonna try I'll tell
okay it's a special case give me a few
minutes okay all right I gotta get a TN
on this he's got to see this you ever
seen this yeah what that look like that
was the that was the end of the previous
where did we urinate from yeah don't we
okay
hold on so so what are those testes
see a hole and where you urinate from
wow all right wow you're 20 22 years of
this thing and you've been so sorry oh
we gonna fix it we Critter fix it we're
gonna fix it okay well y'all know what
y'all got this
a little different huh it's okay to be
different
it is important to do something because
I can tell the quality of life and what
the parents are saying we definitely
need to get rid of that testosterone I
thought also none of it doesn't urinate
or use his penis in an area posture can
get really really infected so we're
going to eliminate that problem by
surgically removing part of the penis
and the creepers around and covering it
up all right let me figure this out
foreign
Ty you know with any kind of major
surgery kind of gets me on edge
keep an eye on the trail there is here
super vascular so
we got a nice bleeder there
all right we're gonna cut him off you go
low
I'm going a little bit lower
nubby's heart rate drops dangerously low
and Dr Hodges orders his team to Halt
the flow of anesthesia
I noticed Paul gets a little nervous and
I'm not used to Paul being nervous
I'm gonna do my part I'm gonna get him
off this table I need you guys to keep
him alive for me okay
[Music]
that's okay Bernie I'm here today with
my bunny Neville it keeps getting
reoccurring ear issues he continuously
scratching his ears gets to the point
where he makes his own ears bleed
sometimes so I brought Neville in hopes
that we can finally get him treated
hello hello hello hey hey how are you
doing today good how are you good doing
good what's this this is never long
bottom oh
so we got some ear issues what we've
been doing when I got him he was living
outside and ever since I had him he's
kind of had these ear issues it's like
it looks like scabs okay you've had it
for how long I've had him for about six
months or so okay I tried to home treat
and Neville with like honey yes you know
Google said it would work
but every couple of weeks it comes back
okay
the internet can be great sometimes for
animals when we're dealing with
husbandry issues or taking care of your
pet
but not when they're sick we want to
make sure that we go to a veterinarian
to make sure we someone who's been
trained to do it because we can run into
a lot of issues listening to the
internet let's check the ears Bud
see anything remember
oh you want to look here
[Music]
sure you have to look real steel don't
move your eyes just watch the stuff
start moving oh man
disgusting we have ear mites oh no
siropty's caniculi commonly known as ear
mites are a parasite which can cause
severe itching and worse
it's not uncommon to see ear mites and
rabbits you're just uncommon to see this
many ear mites in rabbits one of the
worst earbud infestations I've ever seen
it caused them to have inflammation in
the ears and they itch and that's why
the bunny scratches here so they cause a
lot of trauma inside the ear untreated
ear infection if it gets more severe it
can go from the outside area internally
and it can cause deafness we need to get
a sample look on the microscope so we
can be sure when we're dealing with
oh it's in the era no you're not happy
right now huh
come here
to look in this microscope right here
okay okay
you're not gonna get you she's walking
to it like it's gonna it won't jump oh
gosh you see it the good news is we know
what it is the next good news is we're
gonna take care for you thank God okay
we're gonna get on some medication here
to take care of it you tell me that's
been living in his ear a lot of them
have been living in his ear oh yeah so
that's why those ears been bad so I
don't think the honey was gonna do it
well Google said it was going so maybe
next time it's going to call the doctor
Google give me to call Dr Ferguson okay
with an infestation this bad there's no
way a home remedy was going to take care
of it never would have had a severe ear
infection and possible hearing loss so
I'm really glad we were able to treat it
before that happened
so what we're going to do is we're going
to actually get on some medication is
actually for for fleas but it treats the
ear mites okay all right so we're just
gonna part the hair
put it on
and that's it and you're gonna feel
better here in a few days you'll stop
shaking and scratching and all those
things okay I get a rabbit high five
[Laughter]
[Music]
and they look pretty disgusting to be
honest I can't believe that they've been
living in his ears
but thankfully I know what's wrong with
Neville now and we can get him treated
please don't run away
all we do have any reflection
don't have reflexes all right let's cut
them off
I
did not I mean I don't know this dog got
all kinds of anatomical things out of I
I know I just need to get him off my
surgery table
give me some reflex talk to him
all right we coming back there we go
there we go see that tongue
good hey bud I'm not laughing at you I'm
laughing with you buddy all right let's
finish so we get excited about smallest
things in series Believe It or Not
waking up is a big thing
man I am super relieved when we finally
get this dog off the table
after nubby spends time in recovery Dr
Hodges takes him back to his owners oh
yeah we got a package for you
I got a package for you let's let him
see where they got here
so you did do good yes ma'am so so we
took that pre-puse off so I cut this
area down and then I attacked the penis
I scarred around I attacked it here and
we took both of them out we just need to
keep them away from it this area is
going to heal down and see it's not in
any pain we got him on pain medicine
while we're getting a shot and we got
the pain medicine you have so you do
that and you do is antibiotics you
should be great great okay great
I feel tremendously happy right now
because nobody's fine and it's over with
and after going through all this I want
him to live a long life
[Music]
the docs head out to treat a patient
more suited to a sandy desert than
Middle Georgia beware of camel
that's what it says
it's everywhere dog okay
what day is it oh baby
[Laughter]
cast around the camel you don't see a
camel everybody
surely not in Georgia how you doing hey
guys hey how are you good how are y'all
doing great doing great y'all ready for
some fun
Mowgli during his nativity scenes and
Christmas kind of uh showed his manhood
quite early so she totally needs to be
fixed because he's growling and acting a
fool and chasing everything around and
we have little kids out here all the
time Mowgli is our camel he has been
quite aggressive the past couple of
months
the volunteers that come over can't feed
the pastor anymore Mowgli is running
after them and making scary noises so I
knew that it was time to get it fixed we
have a remedy for that yeah okay cooler
removes all the testosterone thanks I
appreciate it thank you
man you're gonna chase a kill well you
scared of a little bit why I am I'm
about to take your official Country Boy
pass
all right it takes about 30 days for the
testosterone to get out the body once we
remove the testicles so get on this
Campbell should calmed down quite a bit
a month from now okay right there
watch his back legs he's never kicked
but he could come on
all right
it's a good try do you want to be real
careful because you know cows kick side
horses kick back but these guys can kick
in every direction
no clothes just a little bit more but
night night my little friend
hold them
come on come on come on come on good job
Molly good
happy this is gonna make you all better
because you won't need a girlfriend
there we go
once we get the medication we're waiting
for
the head to drop some then we get a
little unstudy and wobbly and then we go
down you're here dropping see it
dropping a little bit oh whoa look down
go phrase it here it goes
foreign
but he's not going down without a fight
almost
there we go
just let him go down if that if we just
need a little bit of the blue part yeah
there you go good boy Mowgli just got
him to
get my towel on the head
a towel covers mowgli's eyes to prevent
any visual stimulation that could scare
him and cause him to injure himself or
anyone else during the procedure
Paul I'm gonna switch up I'm gonna get
back there with him I'm Hotel okay
you're gonna take over heart
Andrea yes sir I need a timer
all right
there is a cloud we've probably got 18
minutes before he wakes up let's go to
work boss
escalators are open and ready for you
boss
the docs use an instrument called an
emasculator which crushes and cuts the
spermatic cord at the same time to
prevent hemorrhaging while still
detaching the testicles from the animal
perfect let's go on the next one boss
good job I can hear some gurgling in his
throat now he's starting to make noise
boys just so you know I could hit a
gurgling too okay yeah you're starting
to get louder
all right I mean you'll shot clock is on
but
you got three minutes all right
you can walk her down check not hold us
and then that worked there you go hey
Doc yeah coming up he's starting to come
up yeah he's starting to all right hey
throw your tires anybody
good job go ahead and take your mask
with it off okay perfect all right I'm
switching out okay and he's all yours
Shake It Off
I know you almost can pass the
breathalyzer yeah of course not yet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
right now I want to make sure we
continue to recover from the anesthesia
we up we're a little wobbly but we up
and that's normal we got some drainage
which we expect that because we don't
close the incision in the field so it's
going to have some drainage there just
watch make sure tomorrow we're eating we
up we're back to normal and everything
will be great but it looks good so far
everything looks good and there's one
cowboy George with two less humps
careful designer pencil definitely a
challenge there's so many different
species of Exotics and if you compare
exotic owners to dogs and cats a lot of
people know how to take care of dogs and
cats cause mom had one grand mom had one
sister has one but when you get to
Exotics you may be the only one that had
one and you may not have enough
knowledge in order to care for it so
that makes it difficult for sure
wow
[Music]
how are you doing pretty girl she hasn't
been eating Maybe two or three days it's
not been eating for two three days she
was 9.6 9.6 pounds she's about a little
heavier than a football you want to say
hello
hello
Aku the desert tortoise is here with her
concerned owner what's a normal diet the
whole diet I would give her the salads I
would give her lettuce I would give her
fruits
bananas strawberries diet is everything
so hey I look at that poop
great hey that's great
man you was right on point that's
exactly what I needed you gave me some
poop and I appreciate that food is my
friend because what I'm gonna do is make
sure I don't have any kind of parasites
or anything Hunter Oakley what's called
a fecal float and she'll figure out
exactly what's going on
my fecal flotation is a diagnostic tool
that we use to see if a pet has
parasites what we're looking for is the
eggs to rise up to the top of the
flotation the problem comes when they
have two minutes to count on the slide
that let me know that they are full of
parasites like one versus thousand on
each field we hope that's not the case
hey I look at that poop
Dr Hodges and Andrea run a fecal test on
Aku to determine whether or not
parasites are causing her lack of
appetite
you see anything
no parasites oh great
all right parasites no issues you know
for millions of years they can live out
in a while a lot of times when we bring
them in they don't get the right
vitamins so one of the main things is I
am pretty sure we don't we're missing
vitamin A especially with that diet hypo
vitaminosis basically is low vitamin A
that's your issue my friend
diet is everything the biggest thing
it's called husbands you're basically
it's how you take care of them animal
husbandry is how you take care of
animals what they eat and what they
drink and a lot of times that's the
biggest problem especially with these
animals that people aren't used to
taking care of
you like apricots okay yes I do all
right I want you to share your Apple
cast with this baby okay cantaloupe yes
high in vitamin A I want you to do that
okay you probably don't like broccoli
you like broccoli well it don't matter
you make something you share it with
that's a problem you all the good stuff
you eat you got to make sure she eats it
where you trying to go little girl where
you trying to go you can't go find some
vitamin eh
I'm gonna actually get you some man's
part but also I want you to change the
diet the bit that's gonna be the biggest
thing we want to make sure we get some
foods that are behind vitamin you should
be good to go I sure will not know how
to he's almost like the house of of a
veterinarian if a problem or challenge
comes across he always has a solution
for it for the problem
it's a big puzzle we have to put
together by observing observing and
seeing things then using diagnostic to
try to figure these things out and they
can be difficult and learn to ask the
right questions that's the key that's
the hardest thing that's one thing
so if I know that you brought your dog
in and he's vomiting or has diarrhea and
I know you gave him something from the
table I know you did but I'm not going
to come out and say did you give me
anything from the table no you know I
may say dude you never ate anything that
was strange I may try to work backwards
so I have to back door it and like you
know maybe trash can yeah when you went
looking at something like that and then
when they tell you they're gonna say it
was my husband my husband he likes to
give him a little stuff from the table
which is fine with me I don't care who
did it but now I know what's going on
but again that's the right way private
investigative I guess yeah yeah you have
to
thank you
hey man what's going on not much about
you all right what's going on with that
buddy here I don't know what's happening
with him his mouth he started holding
his mouth funny and I'm thinking it
might be mouth rot but it don't look
like right
hey bud
bearded dragon tank is in trouble
well his mouth went like that and he
just he stopped eating me he's super
dehydrated he is I mean he quit eating
and quit drinking okay
I don't know what's wrong with them I
tried everything I know to get him to
eat I've changed all his Foods he lays
in his water you think he would you know
be drinking but it seems that he don't
drink so I finally saw I got to go
because he's just not going to eat I'm
getting hydrated for you okay give me a
few minutes hey bud come on coming
through coming through coming through
coming to
a cake tray
actually I want to see if we got any
break of the bone in captivity lizards
May develop a Calcium deficiency
resulting in broken bones Dr Hodges
x-rays tank first to check for this you
got it up huh
some remodeling of the bone Swiss Wings
probably do have a Calcium deficiency
even the legs there's some remodeling
so tank the bearded dragon has a really
severe case of Metabolic Bone Disease
you notice that his mouth is deformed as
our bones grow we need calcium this poor
guy's deficient in calcium so the Bones
have broken a little and healed in other
words his bonus structure has
incorrectly remodeled without proper
care Metabolic Bone Disease is
oftentimes fatal
I'm gonna put some fluid subcutaneously
here with the initial exam I think I
noticed he's really dehydrated so I gave
fluids subcutaneously and also we put
them in a bath of warm water and kind of
let mother nature and osmosis work to
kind of get those fluids back in just
kind of hold his head up like that for
me there you go at this point because
tank hadn't eaten in a while and is
really really dehydrated his prognosis
is very very guarded
some bad shape real bad shape we gotta
get you better little boy
hello how you doing good how are you all
right good Dr Ferguson how are you so
Nina nice to meet you doing good doing
good
Zelda a four-year-old mixed breed dog is
here with a suspicious lump over her eye
Zelda is my granddog actually my
daughter rescued her one day while she
was at work she had a rope around her
neck looked like she had been
malnutrition so we brought her home and
she's been with us ever since say a
couple months ago we noticed that I
thought at first maybe an insect bite
but then it's never really gone it's
gone down a little bit it's hard it
doesn't hurt her or anything like that
initially if it's a week or two you
think about some inflammatory or
inflammation response we may have bumped
it or something but if it's going this
long it kind of concerns me that it's
not like a growth of cancer or something
it doesn't have to be anything that's
malignant or anything right but my
recommendation if we get a needle sample
of it make a slide and let the
pathologist look at it okay kind of give
us an indication of what this is okay
then if we do have something that's
cancerous or something we need to remove
then we'll know what we're dealing with
okay but we definitely need to find out
okay okay I'm good all right so we're
going to run back and get that sample
we'll bring the baby back okay that's
good all right
being an owner and hearing that your
animal has cancer is a tough thing me
being a veterinarian have to give that
news no one wants to be to Bear a bad
news but it's something that essential
that we have to do because we need to
get ahead of it and we need to have a
plan on what we need to do for that baby
it could be a tumor
of course I'm
we as their caretakers have to be able
to determine whether or not
they're going to suffer and
I don't think any animal deserves that I
got a syringe I need some just give me
two clean slides please
let's rate this lump on Zelda and I get
just a small amount of material
I'm going to be a little suspicious of
cancer if I pull a fluid back it's going
to be thumbs up but if this lock comes
back and it's cancerous our plan is to
make sure that this cancer has not moved
or metastasized to the lung of the liver
and if it has not our next plan of
action is to remove this growth
that's no part ahead sweetie yeah hole
here
all right you ready
all right you ready
Dr Ferguson is aspirating a suspicious
Mass on Zelda the dog
oh yeah
oh yeah
got some juice in here I think we can
resolve this right here
after aspirating area I found a plus
there is actually an abscess
almost gonna be happy okay and the
upstairs is not necessarily a good thing
but it's definitely not cancer
all right you know the cosmetic surgery
so I'm gonna go in and we're gonna show
Mama this okay okay all right
all right got some good news okay
and an abscess there I know that doesn't
look like good news does it so it's not
a tumor growth or anything so it could
have started from a sting something
could have um stuck us right there and
it closed over and it Formed an abscess
there okay so we got it all drained out
and we're gonna get you on some
antibiotics here okay that's perfect I'm
happy no surgery no tumor nothing else
to deal with later okay so just keep an
eye on that area okay all right thank
you
oh wow that's perfect right are you
happy did you do this she did she's a
sweetie pie
I'm much more relieved with the good
news
say thank you let's go all right thank
you
my biggest thing is about quality of
life and it's good to know that they're
firm Believers in that too let's go see
we're going for a ride
[Music]
shrink a little bit bud
I see your tongue going in now Dr Hodges
checks on tank the bearded dragon to see
how he's doing
all right my friend come on
we in it together though
so he's actually helding his head up now
and he's moving a little bit better so
we're starting to get some Metabolic
Bone Disease so we're gonna try to
supplement calcium more I'm getting
Hydra I put some fluids up under the
skin and I'm I'm gonna give you some
recovery food I'm gonna show you how to
force feet since we hadn't eaten in
about a month we want to make sure that
we get as much nutrients so that the
normal body functions can keep going
we're going to open that little mouth
I'm gonna eat a little bit come on
come on yep when he sticks that tongue
out I mean he swallow and we want to go
right behind the tongue yep right right
there just do one drop
perfect
you got this that man you are natural
even though tank has Metabolic Bone
Disease but getting them rehydrated and
giving them the proper nutrition we can
possibly slow down the disease and
hopefully the tank can go on and live
with a normal life
we're gonna get you some calcium and
we're gonna hook you up man we're gonna
do everything we can to save this baby
you looking up though
ah you're wiggling around
trying to climb out of my box
I think Dr Hodges done well
he's got him hydrated and he's moving
around more so you can only do what you
can do I'm gonna do the best I can to
get him back to where it needs to be
I think we'll get there
we brought Cooper in because his ear was
swollen
and today he's very low energy because
he doesn't feel good I think naturally
freak out a little bit whenever you see
something wrong with your dog so
you know we get a little worried we knew
we just had to bring them in as soon as
we could
hey what we got going on with this baby
today
what's up
you can say swollen tongue let's just
take a peek here
ah
I'm gonna go to oral hematoma
hematoma is when there's blood
encapsulated between the two folds of
the skin oftentimes it's caused by a dog
flapping his head and the vessels break
and that blood just fills up and fills
up and fills up if left untreated it
becomes hot and inflamed and very
painful and uncomfortable for this dog
and we can have a lot of disfiguration
in this ear without surgery Cooper's
aural hematoma could cause permanent
damage to his ear flap what I'll do is
I'll make an incision here we'll kind of
fillet that thing open I'll put it back
together and I'll put stitches in and
we'll have a good flat ear like that
right I'll take this baby with me guys
and we will get that picture you very
well
surgical cases because a tissue called
fibrin starts to form fibrin is normally
a good thing it's a connective tissue
that helps us heal put our inside of the
ear where they want the layer of the ear
to stay closing the heat it won't allow
the air to heal here we go night night
you are getting sleepy you are getting
sleepy
all right I'm going ready for the show
careful with the Mohawk balls careful
with the mohawk
here we go
this thing is actually gonna almost
explode
so make my incision
and as you can see the nice ooze comes
out
because as much as we can
one thing about it when it's been going
on for a while someone's fibrous tissue
see this stuff
is what I worry about
depending how thick the layer of fibrous
tissue is we may have some trouble
getting it out safely because the ear is
very very thin and you have to be really
really careful or you can actually cut
through the air
it's here and it's taking a whole whole
lot of time to scrape away this don't
look good
Dr Hodges carefully Works to repair
Cooper's Ro hematoma
as you can see all this fibrous tissue
that has grown on the cartilage and
since it's been there so long that's
what keeps it from healing which is not
a good thing
Coopers are a hematoma has accumulated
so much blood in his ear It produced a
thick layer of fiber on the cartilage
layer inside so we got to make sure we
scrape away all the fibrous tissue
before we can get it to heal properly or
we could have a lot of disfiguration in
this ear
I'm gonna scrape this a little bit more
all right
the fireman's gone and I have what's
in a country boys terminology they look
like it could be scarified I don't know
if that's in Webster but in Hodges
dictionary startified his word all right
removing the firing allows two surfaces
to form a scar on the inside and a huge
together so once I close it
suture down it's what I call scarifying
and that ear heals perfectly back to
normal
I always tell them when you go home and
when we take the bandages off it may
look like this dog has been in a fight
with Mike Tyson
but I can guarantee you in a few weeks
when the hair grow it and the ear
flattens down you'll never be able to
know what happened ah look at that
beautimus beautimous it is beautiful hey
dog you ought to get that made into a
shirt beautimous right that's my word
beautimus is it let's wrap this ear
so we've done surgery to create this Ro
hematoma the animals in abandons and I
feel like this area will heal very well
the only just have to take good care of
it over the next 10 14 days I feel like
we're going to have a fantastic outcome
after spending time in recovery Cooper
is ready to go home come on Coop time
for you to bust out this joint I know
you got this lamp shade on you know this
guy cool you know this guy
oh he looked a little sad to have a cone
on his head he's never dealt with that
before but you know all in all he looked
good he didn't look to be too upset as
if he was hurting that's good to see I
was worried about him but
it's good to see him okay thanks sir
thank you appreciate it all right
[Music]
hey what's going on what we got today
we've got a Egyptian euromastics okay
oh wow hey how are you you're okay Dr
Hodges is checking out a rather large
lizard I'm here today to get my Egyptian
euromastic scene
um we think she might have eggs because
she has gained quite a bit of weight in
the past six months or so and we're just
worried that she might be egg bound how
are you
you got some eggs in there egg binding
occurs when a female cannot pass the
eggs formed in her reproductive system
your masses are definitely prone to
being egg bound and it can be a very
serious condition because you can have
the eggs ruptured through the uterus you
can have eggs that won't come out and
this animal won't eat and it can be
fatal so we're going to take some X-rays
and see what we have going on here hello
hello how are you you're okay
hey Mama
on the other hand Benny could just be
living her best life eating way too many
snacks and just lounging around hey Mama
I'm really hoping that's the case
because she's looking way too cute right
now
what you got that dog man
we got a uromastic that may have some uh
some eggs in it or maybe we just a
southerner Master maybe that's what it
is yeah maybe some some good soul food
good soul food y'all got me something up
yes sir let's see what we got
so last time I checked eggs around
songs in around you don't see anything
either
a little air in there but like air look
we got some fat yeah maybe there's a
southern uh you're messing up at all
she been enjoying this southern cooking
and snacks a little too much you just
may have a little bit of extra
southernness oh no
no
eggs or anything okay that's good they
look really good all right just help
she's just Southern it's the South
it's really good to know that bendy is
an egg bound besides the excess weight
Ben is really a healthy reptile the only
remedy right now is Diet exercise and
steering clip of second and third health
living good brother she is living good
so bendy's not egg bound thankfully
she's just a little chunky and uh the
her diet I actually have been giving her
food every other day hasn't been working
so the only other option is exercise so
she's just going to go to more events
with us from now on thank you
foreign
Dr Ferguson is headed out to Fort Valley
State University where he and his
technicians need to perform castrations
on some bull calves that belong to the
school's Veterinary Department
all right Trail man you ready ah
castration is kind of a tough time for
me my legs probably be crossed the whole
time while you're doing the procedure I
don't say it don't flip don't get in the
shoe because when I go to work I'm going
to work
but whatever's gonna happen gonna happen
you
better move holla twist do something I
got you
State University is actually University
I attended and we have a very close
relationship with the school and a lot
of times they call us to come out to
help take care of their animals so you
got them round up already we have them
in the shoot the back of the shooting
we're going to run them through the
minutes you're ready we're getting ready
right quick and we'll get them in and
get them knocked out for you okay all
right
castrating calves we like to get them
when they are usually under seven months
old we want to get them before
testosterone starts to kind of roll in
the system because the size of the
vessels that we have to ligate to get
too large so we like to get them early
here
[Music]
together
so he want to go too huh and like he
wanted to volunteer first
and who's going to tell this cow why
don't you come over here and hold and
hold the tail right there
you get the knife
that's good
all right
we know you masculating these
good drill ready there are several
different ways to castrate bull calves
depending on their age the method that I
use I use a device is called a Henderson
emasculator and it basically spin the
spermatic cord until it spins and it
breaks off it's not traumatic not a lot
of bleeding involved and it's very fast
one down you make it look easy come on
over here
it's all right put some spray on there
trying to keep the flies off it's
getting warm now so we don't want flies
laying maggots and eggs in there and
just watch for this regular activity
make sure everything we're eating good
no bleeding don't see excessive bleeding
other than that everything should be
good okay yes sir come on baby come on
out
good deal good deal
all right one down
push it through
just push the cap
he was eager to go and then he saw what
happened to his friends
exactly I don't blame you fella
[Music]
push her through
Dr Ferguson and his team are working
with the bull calf who's in no hurry to
get in the shoot
just push the cap
[Music]
sorry baby I'm sorry bud when they get
that large these bullets are so large we
don't want to give them a tranquilizer
to knock them down just to neuter so we
just neuter them without any anesthesia
we'll be there all day and it's actually
less traumatic on the bull that way
[Music]
combines an antibacterial with the bug
repellent to speed healing and keep
flies out of the area
there's one right there behind Travis
there's another one
my Easter eggs yeah everywhere
all that nasty stuff you eat yeah I
would definitely try it it's good the
seasoning I think we'll have us a little
meal yeah man here in the South Tesco's
are supposed to taste very good I've
never had them just don't leave them up
on your truck seat
it's an acquired taste that I won't
acquire
y'all are disgusting
appreciate the liners come out man yes
sir thanks for your help to the old
school again man yeah okay I've been
seeing you again when you're in the
classroom
you can give me a help though did I get
pretty decent grade when I was in your
class yeah we're a good student okay I
want you to make sure you see everybody
tell them I was a good student because
they don't believe it yes you appreciate
that yes sir all right
yes sir
Fort Valley State University it just has
a special place in my heart that I
couldn't have made it without Fort
Madison State University every day
before about a State College at that
time it's for better State University
now for the newer graduates but now that
we're in the position we're in I want to
go back and be a part of that to help
encourage other students that are there
but we can come in and provide a
practical this is how we do it in
everyday practice and we can give them a
hand on the animals that they have
because they themselves can't take care
of them at all times so we provide that
support for them and we're helping us
that we're helping our soul because we
love to go back we want to give back
nothing like the valley nothing like the
valley
you will come on in they'll be right in
and come get him ten days after Cooper's
rohematoma surgery he's back to have his
stitches removed
[Music]
Cooper's doing much better after a
couple weeks ago getting his ear fixed
hey bud
you got any pain on this thing oh man no
pain last week Cooper came in with a
ballooned ear we called the oral
hematoma most likely were caused by an
inner ear infection and scratching or
flapping of the head this is a very
painful condition and the surgery to fix
this was very bloody so I'm anxious to
see how this ear is healing hey bud all
right here they're nice I remember you
couldn't even touch this dog here yeah
the dog doesn't hurt we bout to send the
dog home with the owner and we're ready
to go
yeah yeah what you think it looks
beautiful that's beautiful
no thank goodness he wagging his tail he
ready to go you're good you're like I
don't want that guy he said let's go
home oh yeah he is good to go let's wait
all right see you later
[Music]
I talked to Nicole and she said uh
Mowgli the camel I'm doing awesome he's
growling and acting a full
oh man so we're thinking he might make
it to the nativity scene
Mowgli was fixed about a month ago
his behavior has changed dramatically
like it is so good you can walk in he'll
come up to you he's just a lot sweeter
doesn't have that bully attitude and
he's not as angry at all and that is
such a blessing
oh I know
with the natoki themes I'm really
actually looking forward to seeing how
he's gonna act during this next
Christmas season
I can see you holding us there the new
TV I might ask it how do I look
native I don't have any lines though I
just stand there oh you just stand there
oh man I I'm only five out of tens I
mean you like six what two that's
perfect nativity scene you don't think 5
10 people everybody
foreign
[Music]
[Music]